to our big story of the day a huge day
for the clark county school district and
families many lower elementary students
returned to campus for the first time in
nearly a year
for the start of hybrid learning 8 news
now reporter christian drummond is live
outside rex bell elementary
where two special guests visited earlier
today kristen
kiersten ccsd superintendent dr jesus
draw
and state superintendent joan eber
coming here to welcome back the students
today
some of the many thousands that are
returning around the valley
along with teachers here are a breakdown
of the numbers
superintendent jarrah says a total of 4
485 pre-kindergarten to third grade
teachers worked today
nearly 3 000 were on a campus and around
1500 worked remotely as for substitutes
490 were in buildings 251 are filling in
for teachers not here
and 239 are long-term subs
filling current vacancies the district
gave families an
option to choose hybrid or distance
education doctor dhara says
that choice remains unavailable during
this transition as well
if there's not enough space then they'll
be put on a wait list
but it'll all be depending on what
families will have the opportunity now
going from
face to face to distance education that
feel uncomfortable that's something that
can happen tomorrow
the other way if we have the space we'll
take them in you know
our educators want to see our kids in
school
here are the cohort numbers nearly 22
000 in cohort a
which they attend class monday and
tuesday and then
online remotely wednesday through friday
roughly twenty thousand in cohort b
going to class remotely
monday through wednesday and in person
thursday and friday
and more than fifty thousand in cohort c
which is
full-time distance education now
dr jarv was acknowledging the
transportation department today
he says the on-time bus rate was nearly
99 percent so a really great start to
kids going back to campus today
reporting live in las vegas kristin
drummond 8 news now